here's what everybody gets wrong about
manifesting
everybody at least kind of in the mass
market
what you're trained to think about when
you think about manifesting is vision
boards and when you hear the word vision
boards you think about the big stuff
should you have big dreams of course you
should should you dream of building a
mansion on the ocean if that's your
thing yes should you dream of the log
cabin yes if you want a lamborghini or
the new ford bronco should you put yeah
yes yes yes if you want the family if
you want the body should you think about
yeah absolutely here's where everybody
goes wrong
you
dream about the end
you make this gorgeous collage of all
this stuff that has nothing to do with
your current life
that literally as you're sitting in your
studio apartment with the cat box that
hasn't been changed in two weeks no food
in the fridge no food in the fridge and
you're looking for a job and you're
staring at a mansion going someday
it's gonna make you feel like a loser
because the gap between where you are
and where you want to go it seems
insurmountable
and so what happens based on the
research is when you only visualize the
end game louis it's demotivating at
first it's really fun to like have a
bottle of wine and make your like
collage i'm going to visualize i'm slap
this up there's my vision board it's
fabulous law of attraction baby come on
come on think about it it's gonna come
to me
okay i've been doing this for two days
i'm not i'm still in this apartment with
the cat box that needs to be changed
the way to visualize properly is to
visualize the bridge
between where you are
and where you need to go the bridge yes
and particularly
the horrible stuff
so let's use your example of the
marathon
the vision board would be lewis crossing
the battle exactly
yes i did it exactly
that will not help you because when you
hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is
sleeting range you say why am i doing
this yes and it feels nothing like that
thing on your vision board you're going
to start a negative dialogue i can't do
this my knees hurt this is not what i
thought it was going to be i'm not ready
for this i didn't train for this i'm
running new york i trained in la are you
running in europe l.a okay good well
then at least you're trained in the
right weather so on and on and on and
you are going to tank yourself
what you do by visualizing the bridge is
you train your nervous system
and your mind
to do the hard work so you should
visualize
not crossing the finish line but what is
it like to be at mile 12 when your
batteries run out on your earbuds yeah
i'm serious and you keep going
what's it like when your shoelace breaks
and now your heel is lifting and you're
starting to get a blood blister at mile
17. what's it feel like when you wake up
and it is pouring rain
and you visualize yourself running
anyway
that way when you visualize the work
you are preparing your body for it so
you're not resistant to it when it comes
when you think a deliberate thought of
what you want
um then law of attraction will employ
the universe
and all people circumstances and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that there is
just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them
to receive what you want and if you
really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
ah all i did was move to here or all i
did was move to there and
i received what i wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it
um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but thoughts
come we energize them and then they will
manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um with another thought with a thought
that contradicts it but i remember
lester levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower to be do
and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization
and these principles that i'm talking
about are a big part of their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
of
a champion tennis player that's a really
big fan of the secret who uses the
sacred this is what he does he sees that
he has won the match before he walks out
onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games
running a race and seeing that they've
won yes they run the race but
what has them win the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and they
visualized
landing back on earth safely
and so that's how important the
visualization visualization is just
bought in pictures by the way it's it's
it's still thought it's just the same
thing okay it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person
thought about what they wanted zero
resistance
locked them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them it might be absolutely
must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have
uh
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so
if we can't think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i got to see this person i got to go
to that meeting i hate doing this and
now they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them into a
predictable future based on what they
did in the past and they've lost their
free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the body is saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh er er you
know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
than step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and you're tweeting
and you're
instagramming and facebooking whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes sit in
the in the silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay i'm going to
feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens there's a
liberation of energy the body goes from
particle to wave from matter to energy
and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else i want to explain
something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was go just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type thon the paradigm
will kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from
475 000 in a year and then i took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
someone said to us one day when we were
trying to get them to focus upon
positive things and we sort of laid out
a list of positive things that she might
think about and she said oh abraham i
don't want those i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then
you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain the pattern of thought that you
have a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others sometimes it
came because of something that you
observed and then talked about and then
remembered and then attracted again and
then talked about it and then remembered
and then attracted again in other words
life is very interesting here isn't it
because you can't talk about anything
for very long before it begins to
replicate itself in your life experience
and it's what makes you develop your
patterns of what you call truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure and then i
pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this sort of
mass consciousness theory that goes like
this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it the
more you're offering the vibration of it
the more the law of attraction lines you
up with it this gathering we're calling
it the art of allowing but what it
really means is the art of telling a
different story the art of telling the
story the way life has helped you carve
it out incrementally but telling the
story with your words with your
observations with your expectations with
your vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are there things in your life that are
not as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better until you are aware of what you
are choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans
said we have been led to believe that
the universe is a great machine
when in fact
it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like
a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conanry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about why is that and so
important as uh sad vijay i just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who's having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard khan henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world and then i give you the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind i say
what's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior
so here's the point when we are in our
conscious mind we are connecting our
spirituality to the biology and the
physical planet that we're in and that
is a creative mind that's the one you
wake up in the morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want
and then you go out and start the day
and then guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 percent of
the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this
we have great wishes and desires and yet
our life is not controlled by that our
life is controlled by the programming
and that programming is the
disempowering program so all you see
is the consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have and
then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator
of your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
when we are very little we learn how to
feel about ourselves and about life
by the reactions of the adults around us
now if you lived with frightened people
or with people who were very unhappy
then you learned a lot of negative
things about yourself and about life
you may still believe them
however this is not to blame our parents
for we are all victims of victims
and they could not possibly have taught
us anything they did not know
if your mother did not know how to love
herself
or your father did not know how to be
gentle and kind
then it would be impossible
for them to teach you to love yourself
or to be gentle and kind
your parents were doing the best they
could with what they had been taught as
children
i also believe that we choose our
parents
each one of us decides to incarnate upon
this planet
at particular points in time and space
i believe we do this because we have
chosen to come here to learn a
particular lesson
that will advance us upon our spiritual
evolutionary pathway
we choose our sex
our color
our country
and then we look around for the
particular set of parents who will
mirror the pattern we are bringing in to
work on in this lifetime
often when we grow up we point our
fingers accusingly at our parents and
whimper you did it to me
but really
we chose them because they were perfect
for what we wanted to work on overcoming
as very little children we learn our
belief systems
and then we move through life creating
experiences to match our beliefs
look back in your own life
and notice how often you have gone
through the same experience
well i believe that you created those
experiences over and over
because they mirrored something that you
believed was true about yourself
it really doesn't matter how long we
have had a problem or how big it is
or how life-threatening it is
the point of power is always in the
present moment
this means
that what you have experienced during
your life
and up to this moment
you have created by your own thoughts
and beliefs of the past
however what you are choosing to think
and believe and say today right here and
right now
is creating your future
your current internal dialogue is
creating tomorrow next week next month
next year etc
notice what you are thinking at this
moment
do you want this thought to be creating
your future
is it negative or positive
just notice
and be aware
i'm not trying to create guilt for
anyone
nor to make anyone wrong
i am making us aware
of what is going on inside of us
many of us who create illness and
dis-ease are in fact totally out of
touch
with what is going on in our minds and
in our bodies
we only notice our bodies when we become
ill
or are in pain
if we do not know what is going on
inside of us
how can we ever change
no matter what the problem is
the only thing we are ever dealing with
is a thought
and a thought can be changed
all our experiences are just outer
effects of our inner dialogue
even self-hatred
is only hating a thought you have about
yourself
you may have a thought that says i'm a
bad person
this thought produces a feeling
and you accept the feeling as true
however
if you eliminate the thought you won't
have the feeling
thoughts can be changed
change the thought and the feeling must
go
believe it or not we do choose our
thoughts
we may habitually think the same thought
over and over so often that it does not
seem that we are choosing the thought
but we did make the original choice
we can refuse to think certain thoughts
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well
you can also refuse to think a negative
thought about yourself
it seems to me
that everyone on this planet that i know
or have worked with is suffering from
self-hatred and guilt to one degree or
another
the more self-hatred and guilt we have
the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves
and we're always trying to please others
or
we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work
on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but you're still just gonna be this
super smart super ambitious person
sitting at home not achieving your goals
you have to do something i look at my
youtube channel as an example uh my main
channel i want to get to 10 million
subscribers that's my next goal right we
hit one we hit two i gotta hit 10.
at the rate that we're growing it's not
fast enough like it's going to take me
way too many years to make it happen so
i need to apply more pressure against it
so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6
000 videos imagine doing split tests on
all of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other one's doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6 000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day i don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're you're going in
circles without any clear direction
most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content
alone is not enough it's the essential
first piece of the ingredient it's it's
essential surrounding yourself with
people who build you up who make you
believe who give you ideas you can act
on that allow you to feel like your
goals are are possible that your dreams
are within reach is super important i do
it every day it's why i create all these
channels i think you should too you'll
notice a difference in how you think
every single day if you are creating
content and consuming content that
builds you up
but then you still have to go take the
second step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a three
point landing question because i want
you to take action you need to teach
yourself that after every video you
watch up to every podcast you listen to
after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your lives you go watch netflix
all day when you get home for five hours
and then go to sleep right you're a
professional consumer but you're
consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you are not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it most people are victims because
of choice or because of expectations
people expect to be victimized they
think
they think they're not very strong and
they're not very capable or they they
don't have very high aspirations that's
if there's anything that i think people
suffer from in this country it's that
not that they fail to achieve so much is
that they fail to aspire they don't have
a sense of their own internal capacities
and greatness or abilities to handle
just about any situation we've talked
about that before but how can a book
tell you how to do this well a book
can't do it for you i'm the first one to
say that absolutely just like going to a
psychiatrist a psychiatrist cannot make
your life any better i'm convinced of
that nor can a valium or anything like
that
it has to be something that you do
internally yourself it can provide your
guidelines it's very much like if you
your car breaks down and you got your
repair manual there you say well why
isn't this manual fixing my car
manuals don't fix cars they can just
give you the information you either do
it to yourself or you don't but can the
book give you a way to rate yourself as
far as what how how victimized you you
really are yeah i i think so uh a lot of
people are very critical of uh books and
self-help books and whether or not they
can really be helpful to people and so
on i know in my own life i've been
really influenced by some very
significant writing of people who've
lived before me a lot of poets uh a lot
of the great you know even mark twain
reading people books have really
influenced my life these kinds of books
influence people's lives today i know it
from the mail that i get and uh well
what's step one
so after you've read the book step one
is to change your expectations around
like every situation you go into all
right you got who victimizes people the
most in our culture family members you
know uh your parents telling you that
you ought to be the way they want you to
be your uh your children telling you
that they expect you to make their
lunches for them they expect you to pick
after the up after them and so on uh
bureaucrats our government uh clerks
people like that waiters tipping when
you're getting bad service all of these
kinds of things you just change around
your expectations you say i am not going
to allow this person or this institution
to get me i'm not going to try to change
it for the whole world but wayne how
specifically i feel sorry for mothers
who are victimized every day i mean by
husbands and by kids you know they have
no they have no self left they give
everything and they but they've taught
themselves that they said to their
husbands or their children uh it's okay
you can push me around if you want to
get uh angry at me or upset at me then
i'll take that and i believe you get
treated in life the way you teach people
to treat you if you've taught people
that you're going to be a dishrag or
you're going to be somebody who's going
to clean up all the time and you're not
going to have any esteem for yourself
then naturally people are going to come
along and just do that but it's a desire
to be approved to be loved so now you're
saying no more mr nice guy i don't think
people are loved i think it's a myth uh
that you that you love dish rags or that
you love people i i think people respect
strength not weakness and you stand up
to somebody you say what's really on
your mind and at first people will feign
it you know they'll fake it they say oh
my god you've really hurt my feelings
that's a strategy that's a technique to
get you you know if i can get you to
come over and visit me on sunday by
using guilt you know and saying oh if
you don't visit me you know it's okay i
went through 18 hours of child labor but
that's okay
and i can use all of this stuff and
you'll come well i'm going to continue
to use that but if you say wait a second
you know i've got a right to decide
where i'm going to be on sunday and i
can't be there this sunday and you're
firm about that you know what happens is
after a while people respect you more
what happens at work though when you go
down and tell that to your boss
the very same thing i'm talking about it
you're fired
no
hardly ever and even if you are it's
generally for the better uh
even on the job people respect strength
you don't want somebody on the job who's
always going to be a yes man who's
always going to you know if you're
trying to run this show and you want to
know how things are going and what the
reactions are and you got a lot of yes
men around you which is like what nixon
had around him everybody's just going
around saying yes sir yes and you find
that the show's ratings are going down
and down and down because people aren't
being willing to be honest with you you
want to have a producer or director or
staff people who are going to say look
this is what you're doing that's not
working this is what's effective you
don't have to be nasty yeah but we
expect that but the question i have is
if you've set a pattern in your
household as a mother or even in a
relationship with a man or vice versa
and you've you've been the giver and the
nice guy all of a sudden when you make
that change then don't people pull back
and say wait you don't love me anymore
yeah they do and that's a technique too
that's a strategy to get you to go back
to uh being a slave again and when they
when you suddenly say to them i love you
it has nothing to do with love it has to
do with my
interest in being my own person and
you're you're using guilt saying you
know you don't love me isn't going to
work anymore how many women how many
times in your life have you gone out
with a man when you were dating or if
you're dating now uh have somebody
called you up and you know you don't
want to go out with this person you know
you nice guy everything is but you know
there's nothing there and you can't say
no yeah and you just say oh well and
then there there you are three weeks
later you're going out on a date and
you're and this guy is coming on to you
know and you're just saying what am i
doing here i know and learning how to
just say no you know i don't want to go
and he says well you know you're hurting
my feelings and i'll probably have to
put my head in the oven and you know any
number
all right all right i'll go i'll go you
know anything you know and this is the
you know that's a victim status you've
got to learn not to make commitments for
things and actually what you're saying
be a little selfish huh
selfish not inconsiderate yes but
selfish definitely in this time yeah
it's your life it's your time it's the
only shot you get at this life and why
should anybody else run it for you seems
like there's an awful lot of selfish
people in the world already well selfish
when you use selfish generally you mean
inconsiderate you know stepping on other
people not caring about others i don't
believe in that i don't do that myself i
spend most of my life in the service of
other people but it's because if you
love yourself you can you can give love
away if you if you can't give away what
you don't have if you don't feel good
that's step one no more mr nice guy
number two
it's like going out and practicing you
know uh really standing up for the
things you know somebody's out there uh
go practice being insulted
if it's necessary but but it isn't
necessary it's you know i have a thing
called being quietly effective john and
it's like you know
a lot of people misconstrue their goals
in life they pull into a gas station all
right and they want their windshield
washed the guy is too busy he doesn't
care he's not interested he doesn't wash
your windshield this person who wants
his windshield what forgets his goal is
just to have a windshield wash that's
all he now says i'm going to reform that
guy how dare he treat me that way who
does he think and he's going to and this
guy's behavior
is suddenly controlling them emotionally
and your goal is just to simply say look
would you mind washing my windshield you
don't have to give a lecture if the guy
says look i'm too busy they say well now
i'm going to talk to the manager or
whatever you know you go on to the next
step or you get out and wash it yourself
it's necessary but you don't allow other
people's behavior to be the controlling
thing of your emotions in your life
whether that's that clerk there or
whether it's your husband or your
children well you said you said
something about explanation what about
people that feel like they've got to
give a long drawn-out explanation with a
thousand reasons and excuses they become
victims you know and then somebody at
the end you know what they'll say i just
don't understand you i don't know
he doesn't
versus cocky i mean confident versus
insulting i mean is there a fine line
you have to learn we learn that the very
specific line confident means standing
up for what you believe cocky or abusive
or conceited means trying to convince
other people of how terrific you are if
you run your life on your inner signals
you don't have any need to show anybody
else how great you are if you're
confident you just simply do it you will
never find working a pleasure if you
hate your job or you can't stand your
boss
what a terrible affirmation that is
it will be impossible for you to ever
attract a great job with that belief
system
if you want to enjoy your time at work
then you must change your thinking
i'm a great believer in blessing with
love every person place and thing at the
workplace
begin with your current job
affirm that this job is merely a
stepping stone to far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking
perhaps you learned your attitude
towards work from your parents
no matter you can change your thinking
now
so bless with love your boss
your co-workers the location the
building the stairs or elevators the
rooms the furniture
and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
i have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work
if you are an owner a manager or a
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful
we all want to be appreciated
acknowledged and encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
consciousness will open the pathway for
you
don't have faith in fear
when you hear of negative trends in
business or in the economy immediately
affirm
that may be true for some but it is not
true for me i always prosper no matter
where i am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make their relationships at work be
smoother
in fact for many people this is a really
big issue in their lives
i am deeply aware that whatever i give
out comes back to me multiplied and this
is true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
divine harmony permeates us all
and we can all flow together in the
workplace in a most productive and
joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the divine right action solution to any
discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any discord or
confusion as it comes up
it's important to release all blame and
turn within to seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do
you're inspired and productive you serve
others willingly and gladly
divine harmony reigns supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to divine principles
then divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers
your consciousness puts you where you
are now your changing consciousness can
lift you to a better position
you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one
before you go to work every day do this
simple exercise just sit comfortably and
concentrate on your breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
to
write or type this affirmation and put
it where you can see it at work
my job is a peaceful haven
i bless my job with love i put love in
every corner
and my job lovingly responds with warmth
and comfort
i am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
i only give out that which i wish to
receive
my love and acceptance of others is
mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work
no matter where i am there is only
infinite good infinite wisdom infinite
harmony and love
many people come to me and say i want to
be a millionaire i i and there's a great
song about i'm going to be a millionaire
and they read things like the secret
which says if you want to be a
millionaire just just wish it and it
will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there are several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth that you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must decide
you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just gonna float around and manifest
millions i'm just gonna sit at home on
my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is i'm going to be a millionaire i'm
going to be a millionaire and they just
try and imagine in the future and the
thing about the mind is the human mind
doesn't future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now
you must be able to think of
how you're going to man what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her father you know this is not
really a good mark she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long
and they work hard on their way to
success they work a lot when they get
success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe
you can be a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something
and some of the smartest people create
things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to attract money into
your life with joe dispenza check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there self-love is no
longer about pleasure or having a car
it's something that you're cultivating
within you so then imagine we have
research to show and this is such a this
is such a
duality